plus grand nombre de cas 1,6 million
cette deuxième vague
contrairement à la première concerne
tout le territoire les métropoles mais
également les villes et les villages
toutes les régions sont concernées
notamment des régions peu touché par la
première vague comme auvergne rhône
alpes provence alpes côte d'azur ou
occitanie chaque jour vous êtes informés
du nombre de personnes qui la veille ont
reçu un résultat positif
ce sont des personnes contaminées il ya
une semaine au moins tester ensuite
c'est l'effet rétroviseur 58000 46
personnes ont reçu hier un test positif
elles ont été exposées plusieurs jours
avant et seront les hospitaliser de
demain surtout si elles sont fragiles ou
âgées
c'est pourquoi nous surveillons
l'incidence le nombre de nouveaux cas en
particulier chez les personnes âgées
nous savons que si l'incidence augmente
mécaniquement les admissions vote
augmentés
quelques jours après la france tu est
massivement plus de 2 millions de tests
par semaine le nombre de tests positifs
augmentent plus rapidement que le nombre
de tests effectués ce le signe que
l'épidémie est massive et qu'elle
diffuse largement en population plus de
20% des tests reviennent polion de tests
ont été réalisés
nous constatons que l'épidémie progresse
en observant l'indicateur du air l'avion
air qui serait à 1,3 cela signifie que
100 personnes porteuses du virus sont
contaminés 130 personnes le nombre de
personnes contaminées va ainsi passer à
130 puis à 169 220 et on a donc doublé
en un peu plus de quinze jours
nous devons freiner tous ensemble la
propagation du virus
vite et fort nous pouvons tous agir sur
cette vague épidémique
il nous faut atteindre les objectifs
fixés par le président la république
diminuer le nombre de contaminés autour
de 5000 par jour réduire le nombre de
personnes qui arrivent à l'hôpital ou en
soins critiques obtenir un air
inférieure à 1
c'est à dire passer 200 personnes
contaminées à 90 puis à 81 et ainsi de
suite
cette évolution épidémique devient sinon
rapidement dangereuse pour notre système
de soins qui doit absorber la mais aussi
tous les autres patients non qu'ovide en
24 heures
nous avons accueilli dans nos hôpitaux
près de 3000 nouveaux malades de l'aco
vie 447 ont été admis en réanimation
un patient sur quatre qui entre en
réanimation ne survivra pas quelques
semaines plus tard depuis mars
trente neuf mille trente sept personnes
sont décédées 29000 au cours de la
première vague et déjà plus de 8000
depuis septembre nous sommes devant une
vague très haute
plusieurs dizaines de milliers de
personnes contaminées chaque jour
entraîne encore davantage de
contamination en quelques jours la
situation se détériore chaque jour
compte nous devons ensemble casser cette
cinétique rapide cette dynamique
épidémique
sauf à laisser des millions de personnes
se contaminent est tombé malade et
souvent gravement
il revient à chacune et chacun d'entre
nous d'agir pour freiner l'épidémie en
appliquant au quotidien les dix mesures
utiles et complémentaires les gestes
barrière la distance la réduction des
contacts le fameux 6 personnes maximum à
table en protégeant nos proches les plus
fragiles nos aînés avec des masques avec
le lavage des mains d'expliquer aux
enfants le port du masque d'aérer
régulièrement tous nous les hutus les
locaux et d'activer l'application tout
senti qu vide
au moindre doute si je suis qu'à
contacter ou que je présente des
symptômes
je fais le test je préviens mes contacts
et je m'isole strictement est
immédiatement protégeons-nous et aidons
les soignants pour merci merci beaucoup
aux professeurs salomon qui vient de
vous l'expliquer la situation dans notre
pays
elle est très sérieuse la deuxième vague
n'est donc pas une abstraction mais elle
est là et elle est violente
face à cela nous sommes totalement
mobilisés depuis des semaines avec un
objectif être capable de soigner tout
les personnes qui doivent bénéficier de
soins qu'elle soit atteinte du
coronavirus ou qu'elles souffrent
d'autres maladies les mesures de
protection
les mesures de freinage qui ont été dès
qu'ils ont été décidées la semaine
dernière avec le confinement sont
dictées par cette volonté elle repose
toute entière sur des projections
précises et des projections à très court
terme en respectant les règles
sanitaires en respectant les gestes
barrières les français aident les
soignants les français aident les
patients les français aident les
français j'en viens à la façon dont ont
pris en charge les patients
d'abord pour vous dire que sur 100
personnes positives au coronavirus 90 ne
vont pas développé de symptômes
c'est donc une forme asymptomatiques ou
alors une formes symptomatiques dites
légères avec des symptômes qui peuvent
être gênants mais qui permettent de
rester chez soi pendant tout le temps de
la maladie et ne nécessite pas de prise
en charge hospitalière 8 % des patients
vont développer des formes
symptomatiques plus sévère avec un
recours nécessaires à l'hôpital avec de
l'oxygène avec des besoins en
médicaments en surveillance qu'ils ne
seront pas néanmoins dans des services
de réanimation ou de soins critiques
mais seront admis dans des lits
d'hospitalisation dite conventionnelle
et enfin il ya 2 % de forme
particulièrement graves qui nécessitent
des soins très spécifiques dans les
services de soins critiques
réanimatoires dans un certain nombre de
cas vous l'avez dit professeur salomon
ces cas peuvent déboucher sur des
complications tellement grave qu'elle
peuvent entraîner le décès du patient
c'est sur cette dernière catégorie de
patients que je souhaiterais m'arrêter
quelques instants sur ces patients qui
sont amenés à être hospitalisées dans
les services de soins critiques
réanimatoires ces derniers jours ces
dernières semaines on a entendu beaucoup
de personnes dire que finalement si on
avait plus de lits de réanimation
on ne se poserait pas la question du
confinement et qu' il suffirait
d'admettre ses patients en réanimation
pour passer la vague
je voudrais vous expliquer pourquoi il
ne suffirait pas de doubler tripler
quadrupler quintuplé que 16 x 20 le
nombre de lits de réanimation pour que
la vie plus
ce continuer d'abord parce que la
réanimation c'est tout sauf un acte
anodin
ce n'est pas une situation banale c'est
pas un mauvais moment à passer
la réanimation quand on y entre on n'est
pas sûr de pouvoir en sortir dans
certains cas on y décède dans d'autres
cas heureusement on y décèdent pas mais
on peut ressortir extrêmement fatigué
avec des séquelles des séquelles
respiratoires des séquelles
cardiovasculaires musculo squelettiques
neurologiques et parfois cognitive je ne
dis pas ça pour faire peur je dis ça
parce que c'est la réalité est qu'on ne
peut pas parler de réanimation avec
légèreté comme s'il s'agissait seulement
de capacité d'accueil et de lits la
réanimation il ya ceux qui l'ont vu et
qui savent que c'est un lieu entre deux
mondes
il ya parfois ceux qui en parlent hier
dans notre pays il n'y avait plus de
4000 patients admis en réanimation pour
qu vide c'est beaucoup les patients
peuvent ils ne sont d'ailleurs pas les
seuls à être en réanimation d'autres
fortes de malades peuvent avoir besoin
de ces 10 des malades qui ont été
victimes d'un accident de la route des
malades qui ont été opérés ou des
malades qui font des complications un
hématome cérébral infarctus du myocarde
grave on estime que quoi qu'il arrive on
a toujours besoin d'au moins 2000 à 3000
lits de réanimation pour ces malades qui
ne sont pas atteints du coronavirus
quand on ajoute ces 3000 patients orco
vide avec les plus de 4000 patients
atteints de co vide dans nos services de
soins critiques l'animateur war on voit
que la pression est déjà très forte elle
est réelle et à date
il ya plus de 85% des vies qui sont
occupées alors j'en viens à la question
qui se pose comment notre système de
santé est il capable de faire face à
cela aujourd'hui comment sera-t-il
capable de faire face à un afflux de
malades graves dans les jours et les
semaines à venir quelles sont les marges
de manoeuvre dont nous pouvons disposer
c'est tout le travail qui a été anticipé
pas seulement par le gouvernement par le
ministère par les agences régionales de
santé mais bien par les soignants et les
directeurs d'hôpitaux depuis des
semaines et des mois
d'abord je voudrais le dire ce sont tous
les hôpitaux publics et privés qui sont
pleinement mobilisés sur tout le
territoire
ils sont capables d'augmenter les
capacités d'accueil en
l'animation cette augmentation de la
capacité elle implique d'abord la
mobilisation de lits de matériel de
réanimation vous le savez désormais
comme des respirateurs des médicaments
de réanimation très spécifique mais
surtout la mobilisation de personnels
soignants formés compétents pour pouvoir
prendre en charge ces malades
d'autre part nous sommes capables de
faire ce qu'on appelle une maîtrise du
flux de patients admis en réanimation et
pour cela nous sommes obligés de faire
des déprogrammations de soi c'est à dire
que les hôpitaux appellent des patients
qui devait subir une intervention
chirurgicale
on leur demandait de repousser cette
intervention de manière à épargner des
blocs opératoires du personnel de blocs
et du personnel de réanimation
pour parvenir à ces objectifs je
voudrais vous détailler concrètement les
leviers qui peuvent être actionnés par
les hôpitaux donc je les dis d'abord la
déprogrammation des soins non urgents
pour libérer des lits et de la ressource
en personnel je vous donne un exemple
c'est la ville du puy en velay à
l'hôpital du puy-en-velay 64 lits de
chirurgie ont déjà été convertis en
lique ovide armés par les infirmiers du
centre hospitalier et bénéficiant d'un
renforcement des équipes qui viennent de
la clinique privée de la même ville du
puy en velay
mais entendons-nous bien qu'on ne
protège pas la santé des seins en
compromettant celle des autres la
déprogrammation des soins elle ne
saurait être totale et on doit limiter
cette déprogrammation l affaire très
progressivement pour éviter des pertes
de chance pour les autres malades
ainsi la prise en charge de certains
patients devra être préservé je pense
notamment à la chirurgie pour cancer à
l'activité de greffe pour les malades
qui sont atteints de pathologies
chroniques de maladies chroniques ou
encore en pédiatrie
je tiens aussi à ce que l'accès aux
soins en santé mentale soient préservés
dans cette période le nombre de lits et
de personnel mobilisables et donc
capable de s'adapter mais il reste in
fine est mort définitive limité par
ailleurs et j'insiste sur ce point les
autres problèmes de santé ne s'arrête
pas avec le coronavirus il faut
impérativement maintenir les
consultations pour les français qui ont
besoin de consulter leur médecin
les cabinets de médecine sont ouverts
les cabinets infirmiers des pharmacies
les quines
et dentistes toute l'activité libérale
continue dans notre pays il est
indispensable de ne pas interrompre le
suivi d'une pathologie chronique ou
lorsqu'on a un doute sur la sévérité de
son état de santé de se rendre si besoin
aux urgences il faut maintenir les
consultations programmées chez le
pédiatre également maintenir le
calendrier vaccinal de nos enfants à
jour j'ai par ailleurs réactiver
l'ensemble des dispositifs dérogatoires
qui avait été mise en place au cours de
la première vague en mac en matière de
télémédecine
ainsi de nombreux professionnels de
santé peuvent répondre à leurs patients
par téléconsultation y compris
d'ailleurs par consultation téléphonique
dans un certain nombre de situations
j'en viens ensuite à la question
cruciale celle du renfort en personnel
soignant parce que sans une grande
mobilisation
nous ne pouvons pas augmenter
suffisamment nos capacités d'accueil
hospitalière
lors de la première vague la
mobilisation des soignants vous le savez
elle a été exceptionnelle dans toute la
france et les régions les plus touchées
ont pu compter sur le renfort en
provenance des régions qui était moins
touché
aujourd'hui à l'heure à laquelle je vous
parle il ya déjà près de 12000
professionnels de santé qui se sont
portés volontaires afin de prêter main
forte à la fois dans les ehpad et à la
fois dans les hôpitaux de notre pays il
est aussi essentiel que les
professionnels de santé puissent être
formés pour prêter main forte à leurs
collègues dans des services à haute
technicité comme la réanimation
c'est pourquoi depuis le printemps nous
avons organisé et réalisé la formation
de plus de 7000 professionnels de santé
1500 autres professionnels sont
actuellement en cours d'être formés pour
pouvoir prêter main forte à leurs
collègues
un exemple territoriale en normandie au
centre hospitalier de saint-lô ce sont
65 professionnels paramédicaux qui ont
été formés aux techniques réanimatoires
c'est un appui considérable et partout
où je me rends dans tous les services de
réanimation et de soins critiques
les équipes me disent qu'ils apprécient
qu'ils ont besoin de ce renfort les
étudiants en santé en soins infirmiers
et en médecine les professionnels en
formation sont également mobilisés pour
renforcer les équipes et je tiens à leur
rendre un hommage particulier parce que
cette crise sanitaire bouscule le
déroulement de leur formation
c'est précieux pour les hôpitaux les
étudiants en soins infirmiers par
exemple peuvent intervenir en renfort
comme aide-soignant ce qui fait un
potentiel total de 8000 aides soignants
supplémentaires d'ici à la fin de
l'année je veux ici leur exprimer toute
ma gratitude parce que leur engagement
est total
d'ailleurs les étudiants en médecine et
les internes peuvent être affectés à la
prise en charge également des patients
qu'aux vide et je lis et je les en
remercie
si la mobilisation est là et bien là
elle n'est pas infinie on ne peut donc
pas se dire c'est bon il ya du renfort
il ya du monde en plus ça va passer ça
ne suffit pas j'en arrive donc un autre
levier que nous pouvons actionner quand
la situation l'exigeait celui des
évacuations sanitaires
les évacuations sanitaires elles ont été
à nouveau mise en oeuvre depuis quelques
jours dans notre pays
elle vise à donner des marges de
manoeuvre aux établissements de santé
quand le niveau de pression sanitaire
dans l'hôpital se fait trop fort alors
il ya des transferts qui peuvent être
organisées entre hôpitaux au sein d'une
même région
mais je vais aussi vous parler des
évacuations sanitaires entre différentes
régions
c'était nous nous en souvenons une image
forte de la première vague épidémique
pour cette deuxième vague déjà 60
transferts de patients d'une région à
une autre ont été réalisés la région
auvergne rhône-alpes qui est ce jour la
région la plus touchée par l'épidémie a
déjà procédé à 43 évacuations sanitaires
200 nouvelles évacuations sanitaires
sont prévus parce qu'il est
indispensable de prévenir plutôt que
subir et nous préférons réalisé deux
premières évacuations
lorsque nous pouvons le faire dans des
conditions de sécurité maximale
voyez sur votre carte que ce sont les
régions de pays de loire de nouvelles
aquitaine les régions également bretagne
qui ont reçu déjà un certain nombre de
patients en provenance des régions plus
touchées
là encore à l'efficacité de ce
dispositif peut nous rassurer mais je
rappelle que ce sont des opérations qui
sont logistiquement et humainement très
lourde et qui ne peuvent pas être mises
en oeuvre pour des volumes très
importants de malades mais pour des
volumes de patients réduit et puis une
évacuation sanitaire ne peut pas être
effectué avec n'importe quel malade il
faut quand même un patient qui
qu'il soit en état grave soit stabilisée
poursuivre pour supporter le transfert
au delà de l'hôpital c'est tout notre
système de santé qui est sur le pont ce
afin de limiter l'impact de l'épidémie
sur l'hôpital et les réanimations la
coordination entre la médecine de ville
les établissements médico-sociaux les
ehpad les établissements accueillant des
personnes handicapées et l'hôpital
permettent aujourd'hui de mieux prendre
en charge les patients qu'ovide qu'au
cours de la première vague et finalement
de ne recourir à l'hôpital que quand
c'est parfaitement nécessaire voire à la
réanimation quand c'est évidemment
nécessaire je le dis c'est une vraie
différence avec la première vague ou la
gestion était très hospital au centre
est et ce pour plusieurs raisons
aujourd'hui nous savons que chaque
composante du système de soins a un rôle
entier à jouer pour préserver les
services hospitaliers mais aussi parce
que ça ne présente pas de risque pour
les malades quand ils présentent des
formes peu sévères que d'être suivie en
ville par leur médecine de ville par
leur infirmière et c'est important de
pouvoir le souligner la médecine de
ville peut être mise à contribution
d'ailleurs y compris pour des situations
où il y aurait des besoins faible en
oxygène pour des patients qui auraient
des formes symptomatiques
il est très important que chacun puisse
savoir quel rôle il a à tenir dans le
dispositif de soins pour les malades et
des recommandations sont actuellement en
train d'être finalisées en lien entre la
haute autorité de santé et les sociétés
savantes et qui seront bientôt très
prochainement distribuerez distribué
très largement à l'ensemble des acteurs
de la médecine de ville qui pourront
ainsi s'appuyer sur ses recommandations
en termes de prise en charge de
traitement est de savoir quand
transférer un patient à l'hôpital
ce travail concret entre la médecine de
ville et l'hôpital il vous sera
détaillée par l'exemple dans quelques
minutes avec le docteur edouard devaux
du centre hospitalier de pontoise
médecin interniste et le docteur michel
baud médecin généraliste à
deuil-la-barre mesdames messieurs pour
faire face à une reprise épidémique très
forte les capacités de réanimation vous
le voyez sont mobilisés préparer
augmenter au fur et à mesure qu'ils
aient besoin arrive il ne servirait à
rien aujourd'hui de déprogrammer la
totalité des soins sur tout le
territoire pour monter directement a dit
ou plus de réanimation en réalité de
l'hôpital s'adapte au fur et à mesure
que les besoins augmentent de manière à
ne déprogramme et les soins que lorsque
c'est devenu véritablement indispensable
pour rappel nous avions dans notre pays
quelques 5000 lits de réanimation
nous avons augmenté à l'issue de la
première vague de façon constante de 15%
le nombre de lits de réanimation pour
monter à un peu plus de 5800 lit de
réarmer équipé au 30 octobre les
réanimations augmenter leurs capacités
progressivement elle était assise 1500
lits l'augmentation est toujours en
cours elle se fera je le redis
progressivement en fonction des besoins
exprimés avec pour objectif d'être
capable d'atteindre ce que nous avions
réalisé le 15 avril dernier il y avait
eu dix mille 700 lits de réanimation
équipe est armée et on sait que les
efforts étaient très importants pour y
arriver
par ailleurs on fait ce qu'on appelle
une dilatation de l'ensemble des
structures hospitalières des soins
intensifs des soins critiques des soins
continus des lits de médecine
conventionnelle des lits de rééducation
et de réadaptation pour pouvoir
augmenter encore ses capacités au delà
et être capable d'accueillir des
patients qui présenteraient des formes
sévères avec des besoins en oxygène
parfois en dehors des lits de
réanimation mais dans des conditions de
sécurité sanitaire et de qualité des
soins garantie j'en viens maintenant à
l'impact de l'épidémie sur notre système
de soins finalement qu'est ce qui se
serait passé si nous n'avions pas pris
des décisions
d'abord de fermer les établissements
recevant du public de limiter les grands
rassemblements de demander aux français
de faire encore plus d'efforts dans le
respect des gestes barrières de limiter
eux mêmes leur réunion y compris dans la
sphère privée
que se serait-il passé si nous n'avions
pas fermer les bars les restaurants dans
les métropoles où le virus circule et le
plus que se serait-il passé si nous
n'avions pas instaurer un couvre-feu
dans notre pays est finalement mis en
place ce nouveau confinement
nous ne sommes pas dans des projections
vague nous sommes nous nous appuyons en
permanence sur des modélisations les
modélisations de l'institut pasteur que
j'ai déjà eu l'occasion de vous
présenter si l'ue nous n'avions rien
fait il y aurait eu à la mi-novembre
dans quelques jours quelques 9000
malades atteints du coronavirus dans les
réanimations française ça aurait été une
situation je le dis
catastrophique pour nos hôpitaux et pour
les malades je précise que ses courbes
ne prennent en compte que les patients
coded donc il faut ajouter aux courbes
que vous avez tous les patients qui sont
de toute façon en réanimation pour
d'autres raisons
quel coronavirus concrètement dès le 11
novembre vous le voyez toutes les
animations nos hôpitaux auraient été
saturé et la deuxième vague aurait été
très clairement beaucoup plus forte que
la première en terme d'impact sanitaire
je vais faire un focus sur la région
auvergne rhône-alpes qui est la région
la plus touchée je le disais par la
deuxième vague
je ne vis pas du tout la stigmatiser
d'autant que c'est ma propre région mais
parce que c'est la région la plus
touchée aujourd'hui à la mi novembre
s'il n'y avait pas eu ces mesures mises
en place à la mi novembre il y aurait eu
deux fois plus de patients atteints de
co vide en réanimation que la capacité
max cheap maximale de la réanimation de
toute cette région n'était pas
soutenable
il fallait à tout prix d'éviter si le
confinement est bien observer que se
passera-t-il si le confinement est bien
observé jérôme sur le monde a dit le
virus circulera
- nous serons capables de réduire
progressivement cette circulation
et comme nous l'avions fait au printemps
dernier de réduire le nombre de
nouvelles contaminations et de baisser
la charge sanitaire vous le voyez sur la
courbe à la mi novembre le nombre de
patients qu'ovide atteindrait alors un
pic d'environ 6000 patients qu'aux vide
en réanimation 6000 patients c'est
beaucoup quand même
auxquels il faut ajouter les 3000
malades non covit je le répète ce qui
veut dire que nous aurions quand même
une pression très forte sur l'ensemble
de notre système hospitalier
la vague serait donc très forte mais
elle serait moins intense que la
première vague
encore une fois ça demande un strict
respect des règles de confinement de
l'application des règles sanitaires et
des gestes barrières la durée des règles
et la durée des restrictions dépend donc
en très très grande partie de nous et de
notre capacité à être solidaires et à
tenir bon
plon il plus nous serons rigoureux - le
confinement sera la même en respectant
scrupuleusement ces règles sanitaires
dans l'hypothèse d'un air à 09 c'est à
dire ou le confinement serait bien
respecté
la région auvergne rhône-alpes
pourraient connaître une saturation de
sakha de ses capacités de réanimation et
c'est pour cela que nous procédons sans
attendre à des évacuations sanitaires
vers d'autres
lyon a contrario si nous ne respectons
pas suffisamment le confinement si le
virus continue à circuler sur le rythme
qui est le sien actuellement avec un air
estimé à environ 1,2 alors nous
connaîtrons un risque fort de saturation
au niveau national dès la mi-novembre
avec plus de 7000 patients atteints de
co vide en réanimation c'est à dire plus
de 70 % de la capacité maximale de north
et à juste avec des patients atteints de
colite cette deuxième vague serait donc
plus haute que la première elle serait
plus longue que la première avec un
nombre croissant et une probable
stabilisation à un niveau élevé de
patients en réanimation et ce au moins
jusqu'à la mi décembre toujours dans la
région auvergne rhône alpes la situation
serait encore plus que problématique
avec une saturation dès les prochains
jours des réa et implique à 1700
patients qu'aux vide en réanimation
réanimatoires sur cette région
en utilisation réanimatoires sur cette
région pour une capacité maximale
d'environ 1000 lits dames et messieurs
vous l'aurez compris nous devons
respecter le confinement
nous devons respecter les règles
sanitaires être extrêmement attentif
voilà où nous en sommes en toute
transparence
la situation est l'étendue c'est rien de
le dire et nous devons tenir et nous
allons tenir parce que nous l'avons déjà
fait c'est pour ça que nous nous nous
battons au quotidien pour que les
efforts acceptée par les français soient
le plus efficaces possible ce afin de
bloquer la circulation du virus
je suis je disais tout à l'heure entouré
de deux médecins un médecin hospitalier
médecin interniste spécialiste en
maladies infectieuses à pontoise et un
médecin de ville
un médecin généraliste parce que comme
je vous l'aï dit tout à l'heure c'est
bien l'ensemble du système de soins qui
est mobilisée pour lutter contre
l'épidémie
il veut leur passé la parole et ils vous
vous présentez par l'exemple ce qu'ils
sont capables de mobiliser sur leur
territoire pour améliorer la
coordination des soins entre la ville et
l'hôpital et changer la façon finalement
de soigner les malades du coded autant
que c'est possible de le faire pour les
formes moins grave de coronavirus j'ai
passé d'abord la parole au docteur beau
médecin généraliste qui va venir vous
présenter tout ça
merci monsieur le ministre il ya une
grande différence entre ce qui s'était
passé pendant cette première vague et ce
qui se passe dans cette deuxième vague
dans cette première vague on ne
connaissait pas bien personne ne
connaissait pas plus ses médecins
généralistes évidemment que les médecins
hospitaliers le fonctionnement du virus
est évidemment les les conséquences
qu'il pouvait avoir à différentes phases
de l'évolution de la maladie
et là la grande différence c'est que
maintenant on s'est beaucoup mieux on
peut pas dire parfaitement ce que les
effets que va avoir un virus qui est
devenu quand même très prévisible qui
n'a pas évolué donc ou dont les
conséquences seront toujours les mêmes
et c'est vrai que ça change tout ça
change tout parce que il est important
que la médecine de ville qui aura un
rôle important beaucoup plus important à
jouer dans la première vague puissent
être efficaces pour pouvoir prendre en
charge correctement les patients
notamment les patients qui ont des
facteurs de risque particuliers
notamment les patients âgés et les
patients qui vont présenter des formes
graves on sait déjà que selon début
d'entrée dans la maladie on peut déjà
prévoir ce qui va se passer dans les ca
secondaire et notamment dans la phase
inflammatoires la troisième phase est
donc c'est pour ça qu'il est très
important que les médecins de ville soit
organisée de façon à prendre en charge
de façon plus efficiente possible les
patients et de façon à ce que si un
patient est hospitalisé le soit dans les
meilleures conditions et au bon moment
d'où l'intérêt d'une prise en charge qui
se fait du début à la fin
un des patients et qu' aucun patient ne
notamment nous tous ces patients à
risque aucun de ces patients quitte les
radars qu'aucun patient ne soit pas sous
surveillance
à part ce système de médecine de ville
alors sur un territoire à deuil-la-barre
comme disait tout à l'heure on a
organisé sur quatre communes deuil la
barre anguilles à montmorency et
montmagny une prise en charge qu'on a
voulu territoriales
avec des partenaires évidemment
multiples et notamment les partenaires
des collectivités territoriales les
mairies qui met à disposition évidemment
un certain nombre de personnels pour
pouvoir justement favoriser et aider à
se suivre tout ça se fait en partenariat
évidemment avec la rs et nous nous avons
un objectif de 2 vraiment suivre le
patient du début à la fin et donc il
nous l'expliqué clairement le
cheminement c'est à dire que on a sur ce
territoire un ensemble de centres de
prélèvement dans chaque centre de
prélèvement tous les patients qui vont
venir notamment ceux dont on parlait
ceux qui sont à risque seront pris en
charge directement c'est à dire que
d'emblée ils vont rentrer dans une
application numérique 1 qui permettra
d'avoir un suivi interactif ils seront
ensuite prélevé par des infirmières donc
qui feront le test de pcr et qui
rentreront toutes les données médicales
de ses patients et ce patient donc
rentrera dans un suivi interactif dès le
début de sa pathologie jusqu'au 14e tour
qui a à peu près le jour ont pensé qu'il
y aura plus trop de problèmes et ça
c'est une organisation qui qu'on a mis
en place et qui se fait donc avec une
cellule d'appui à la coordination qui
s'appelle le dac qui dit sur tous les
territoires mais notamment le nôtre et
avec donc des professionnels 1 qui vont
suivre évidemment sur cette application
numérique
l'évolution des différentes pathologies
et qu'ils vont pouvoir faire aussi en
appui avec les fonctionnaires
territoriaux du rappel de patients de du
suivi de tous ces patients de façon à
les suivre à la fois sur le flanc
médical voire sur le plan social ça
implique que à certains moments de cette
évolution ou pourra faire appel des
cellules d'intervention mobile restait
sur quelque chose de simple qui sont
fait qu'ils sont constitués de
d'infirmières et de médecins qui sont
donc un groupe qu'on a constitué et qui
en partenariat avec les médecins
hospitaliers que ce soit les
infectiologues où les réanimateurs là on
est en forme et justement à ces
pratiques en étant mieux formés ou à la
prise en charge de ces patients
donc dans cette deuxième vague pourront
alors pour les infirmières évidemment
surveiller l'évolution de la maladie
1 quand elles seront alcan ils seront
alertés par la cellule de suivi à parce
qu'un patient va se dégrader ou qu'il va
aller moins bien et faire intervenir
évidemment des médecins qui pourront
entreprendre déjà un des soins qui sont
devenus maintenant possible et qu'ils ne
l'étaient pas évidemment pendant cette
première phase
on en reparlera tout à l'heure mais ça
peut être évidemment ça vous le savez
bien les mises sous anticoagulants
l'espagne de bas poids moléculaire
l'oxygène les corticoïdes en fait un
certain nombre de choses
tout cela nécessite évidemment des
partenariats de l'aide du territoire des
liens directs avec l'hôpital dé lien
constant avec l'hôpital à la fois quand
on a à suivre l'évolution d'une
pathologie à savoir si c'est le bon
moment de faire telle ou telle
thérapeutique est de savoir quelle est
l'évolution du patient comment il faut
assurer son suivi
elle d'en haut niveau de son domicile ou
s'il faut de l'hospitaliser donc de
faire en sorte que les prises en charge
sur un territoire soit beaucoup plus
pertinentes soient beaucoup plus apaisé
de façon à ce que chaque patient soit
vraiment suivi et que on interviennent
toujours au bon moment et toujours avec
les solutions les plus pertinentes de
traitement
ça demande une implication des
professionnels de santé qui le sont sans
problème les médecins et les infirmiers
sont vraiment très impliqué un depuis le
début dans cette démarche de soin et je
dirais même qu'ils son enthousiasme à
l'idée de pouvoir maintenant travailler
autrement de façon plus efficace et 2
passes ont beaucoup plus partenarial
avec l'hôpital de façon à assurer le
meilleur suivi du début à la fin de
chacun des patients merci beaucoup aux
docteurs pour ses explications pas sa
parole au docteur de vaud qui est
médecin hospitalier elle près de
pontoise
merci monsieur le ministre michel je
vais revenir un tout petit peu sur la
première vague si vous le voulez bien
il a échappé à personne que nous avons
pu à gérer un événement salutaire
absolument inconnu d'un virus que nous
ne connaissions pas
l'année dernière et qui nous a posé
beaucoup de problèmes néanmoins j'ai été
surpris très agréablement surpris de
voir à quelle vitesse nous avons acquis
agrégé la connaissance à l'intérieur des
hôpitaux dans toutes les organisations
qui ont participé à la lutte contre le
virus pour venir à bout finalement de
cette première vague l'été à laon les
connaissances se sont consolidées et
aujourd'hui ce qui nous apparaissait
comme quelque chose de douteux
auparavant des molécules qui était à
l'essai sont aujourd'hui confirmées ou
infirmées dans leur utilité et nous
avons les moyens à présent d'avoir des
parcours de soins pour les malades
atteints de colite 19 beaucoup plus
sécurisée que pendant la première vague
c'est une donnée très importante parce
que comme nous l'avons vu les chiffres
montrent que cette seconde vague
elle a une ampleur qui est probablement
beaucoup plus importante que la première
elle atteint tout territoire elles
concernent beaucoup plus de gens et vous
le savez monsieur le ministre l'a
rappelé tout à l'heure 90% des gens qui
sont atteints de cette maladie vont le
faire dans sur un mode assez bénin le
virus aura peu d'impact sur eux
néanmoins ça ne les dispense pas d'être
soigné et pris en charge d'être rassurés
et d'être conduit dans l'ensemble de
l'évolution de leur maladie
la connaissance qu'on a acquis à
l'hôpital pendant la première vague a
été un petit peu néanmoins un peu
séquestrés je vais dire à l'intérieur
des hôpitaux et il m'a paru très
important voire fondamental qu'elle soit
complètement redistribuées à tous les
acteurs de soins à tous les acteurs de
santé des territoires
afin que nous puissions avoir une prise
en charge faite sur ces territoires par
ce que j'appellerais mois une équipe
sanitaire territoriales ça dépasse
l'hôpital ça va bien au delà ce sont
tous les acteurs de soins qui se mettent
ensemble sur une prise en charge
complètement coordonnée est complètement
sécurisé pour les malades c'est ça qui
est important
le tout hôpital ça n'est pas possible
et monsieur ministre a rappelé tout à
l'heure en évoquant la réanimation
entrer dans une réanimation être soigné
dans une réanimation peut être un
événement extrêmement traumatisant on
peut presque décliner ce raisonnement à
l'hôpital dans son intégralité être
hospitalisé ça n'est jamais anodin ça
peut être un événement porteur de
risques on a tendance à penser que
l'hôpital
tout est bien mais néanmoins c'est un
milieu où il ya du risque et c'est un
milieu où ne serait ce qui reste est
privé de la visite des siens dans un
milieu où l' angoisse est importante
parce qu'on est malade il peut être
difficile d'y rester et cela peut être
traumatisant comme je les dis il y a
quelques secondes pour cela nous devons
faire appelle donc à tous les acteurs de
santé du territoire pour partager la
prise en charge coordonnée de tous les
malades atteints de colite 19 parce que
justement éviter l'hôpital c'est dans la
majeure partie des cas puisque dans la
majeure partie des cas la prise en
charge ne relèvera pas de l'hôpital
cette prise en charge pourra se faire de
façon plus sereine
alors jusqu'où on peut aller aujourd'hui
dans la ville dès lors que la
connaissance est redistribué qu'on
encadre la prise en charge dans des
protocoles qui sont parfaitement
sécuritaire parce que l'on maîtrise
aujourd'hui mieux des thérapeutiques et
notamment un grand trépied qui a évoqué
le michel qui est la prévention des
complications retardé de lakovic 19 avec
une anticoagulation lorsque les définit
avec de l'oxygène qui avant pendant la
première va conditionner une
hospitalisation certaine et puis
maintenant quelques traitements qui sont
dans cette phase où
il ya probablement une aggravation et où
les malades sont oxigeno dépendant on
peut parfois s'affranchir de
l'hospitalisation et puis aussi sur un
séjour hospitalier pour le rendre le
plus court possible et le moins
traumatisant possible permettre à nos
collègues de la ville en parfaite
coordination avec les acteurs de
l'hôpital de hull permettre aux patients
un retour plus précoce à leur domicile
et la fin de la prise en charge de la
copie de 19 depuis le domicile parce que
vous le savez probablement certains
malades vont rester dépendante de
l'oxygène en avoir besoin de
réhabilitation vont avoir besoin de
soins du tri sionnel et tout cela ça
peut se faire très facilement à la en
ville dès lors que les soins sont
coordonnés et donc nous avons ensemble
construit sur notre territoire un
protocole de coordination ville-hôpital
parfaitement concret actif dès à présent
et nous vous quitteront tout à l'heure
pour rejoindre l'hôpital de pontoise
parce que nous avons une grande
conférence de formation 20h30 jusqu'à
22h30 sur la coordination ville-hôpital
kobe de 19 entre la médecine de ville et
les médecins hospitaliers
je vous remercie c'est moi qui vous
remercie l'auteur de vaud pour ses
explications très claires j'ajoute que
je crois que votre séminaire qui sera à
10 ans distant ciel tout à l'heure au
groupe pas loin de 1000 médecins ce que
vous disiez tout à l'heure dans cet
important d'avoir ce point d'explication
sur la coopération entre la ville et
l'hôpital sur les façons de traiter
alors je le dis tout de suite parce que
vous avez entendu des noms de
médicaments tels que anticoagulant ou
dérivées de la cortisone
ce sont des médicaments qui sont
évidemment prescrits par les médecins
dans certaines situations qu'ils exigent
et notamment avec ans lorsqu'il y avait
besoin d'oxygène
tout cela fait l'objet de
recommandations de la part des sociétés
savantes et de la part des experts qui
seront partagés avec l'ensemble des
médecins de la ville et de l'hôpital de
manière à guider chacun dans le parcours
de soins des malades
je vous remercie beaucoup pour tout le
travail que vous faites sur le
territoire sur votre territoire et j'en
profite pour saluer l'action remarqua de
l'ensemble des soignants en ville comme
à l'hôpital qui sont dévouées jour et
nuit vous le savez pour soigner pour
sauver des vies
et on leur doit énormément pour conclure
vous dire que face à l'amertume face à
la fatigue face à une lassitude qui est
légitime face au tfc isme nous devons
nous nous ressaisir et nous devons
continuer à nous battre
les jours et les semaines qui viennent
vous l'avez vue seront difficiles sur le
plan sanitaire
notre système de santé est organisée
pour pouvoir y faire face dans les
meilleures conditions possibles
il faut le dire et je vous le dis nous
devons tenir et nous allons tenir
je vous remercie je prends des questions
nous passons aux questions des
internautes
d'abord la première question de
christophe les ehpad sont de plus en
plus touchés que faites vous pour les
aider c'est vrai que les établissements
qui reçoivent des personnes âgées les
ehpad sont de plus en plus touchée il y
as je crois aujourd'hui 15% des ehpad
qui ont déclaré au moins un cas de
corona virus et on sait que dans les
ehpad les personnes sont
particulièrement fragiles et qu'il ya un
grand nombre de décès qui petit être
observés c'était le cas pendant la
première vague
c'est pourquoi nous avons mis en place
des protocoles sanitaires depuis la
première vague qui ont été réadaptée
constamment en coopération avec les
directeurs des ehpad et les équipes
soignantes et ses protocoles permet de
garantir à la fois je dirais la
protection des personnes est à la fois
de se prémunir du risque d'isolement
c'est pourquoi les visites sont
autorisés en respectant bien le
protocole sanitaire toujours et des
décisions locales peuvent être prises
lorsque la situation et un échappement
par ailleurs vous donner quelques
exemples d'actions qui sont menées en ce
moment une vaste campagne de dépistage
par des tests anti génique rapide est en
cours six cent cinquante mille tests
antigénique sont déployés dans les ehpad
de tout le pays et un autre exemple je
le disais tout à l'heure
plusieurs milliers de soignants sont
venus prêter main forte aux équipes dans
les ehpad dans la période
une question de julie j'ai entendu dire
que les tests anti chine x étaient plus
rapides que les tests pcr pourquoi on ne
les déploie pas et on les déploient les
tests antigénique on a commencé à les
déployer ça fait plusieurs semaines
c'est un déploiement qui se fait
progressivement qui va devenir petit à
petit de plus en plus visibles les têtes
antigénique ne remplaceront pas les
tests pcr l'état senti génie qu'ils ont
deux grands intérêts
d'abord dans ce qu'on appelle le
dépistage en population mettons vous
alliez vous décidiez de dépister
universités eh bien vous allez déployés
là-bas des tests antigénique j'ai des
gens qui n'ont pas de symptômes et vous
allez identifier un certain nombre de
personnes qui seront peut être contaminé
par le caue vides et qu'il ne savait pas
la deuxième grande indications c'est le
diagnostic individuel celui ci il est
réservé pour les patients âgés de moins
de 65 ans et qui ont des symptômes et là
ils peuvent désormais bénéficier de
tests antigénique c'est vrai que le
résultat est très rapide 15 20 minutes
et les pharmaciens d'officine ont
commencé à en acheter sondés qui est
comme en cent réalisés à paris certaines
le font déjà et ça va monter en
puissance très vite vous verrez les
médecins également mais également les
infirmiers libéraux font des tests
antigénique donc c'est un complément ça
ne remplacera pas les deux millions de
tests que nous faisons chaque semaine
mais ça viendra
en plus du reste pour nous aider dans
notre stratégie est une question pour
karim
je vois beaucoup de personnes dans la
rue le confinant n'est-il pas trop
souple vous voyez plus de gens dans la
rue que lors du confinement au printemps
dernier c'est un fait mais il ya
plusieurs raisons à cela
vous emmenez vos enfants à l'école vous
allez les chercher à l'école et vous
allez au travail s'ils sont les deux
grandes différences par rapport aux
premiers confinement et ça explique que
vous puissiez croiser un peu plus de
monde aux heures de pointe moi je crois
intimement que le confinement
il est respecté par les français 1 parce
qu'ils ont compris l'intérêt de le faire
et ils ont compris que en respectant le
confinement il pourrait sauver des vies
et on pourrait retrouver plus rapidement
une vie plus normale que celle que nous
connaissons aujourd'hui
et puis ya des signes qui ne trompent
pas la réduction très importante du
trafic ratp par exemple de la
fréquentation du trafic ratp dès le
premier jour elle était tombée à 50 de
même à 25 % à certaines heures du train
de la fréquentation normale
on voit également des signes de
fréquentation des routes qui montre les
gens prennent moins leur voiture il ya
beaucoup moins de déplacements et donc
on retrouve là une dynamique qu'on avait
pu connaître lors du premier compenser
84 que vous avez annoncé tout à l'heure
bon laissons d'alger était quand même un
petit peu orienté et c'est donc moi
personnellement les sondages je n'y
crois pas beaucoup je crois aux réalités
du terrain yannick jadot a justement
indiqué qu'en france il faudra sortir de
la chasse et il a considéré que voilà
cette pratique ne devait plus être un
loisir qu'est ce cas qu'est ce que vous
lui répondrai
mais je leur répondrai que pourquoi est
ce que il faudrait sortir de la chasse
je pense que ça fait partie de notre
patrimoine culturel français c'est une
tradition c'est quelque chose de très
beau d'ancestrales sans la chasse on ne
serait pas là ni vous et moi donc
donc pourquoi pour la saison 2010 9 2020
il ya eu quelques il ya eu des accidents
et on en dénombre 100 cas on dont 240 et
une victimes causées par par exemple des
mauvaises manipulations d'armes
on a des mauvais tir c'est plus que
l'année dernière est la plupart des
victimes sont des chasseurs mais pas
toujours
est ce que c'est une passion qui bat a
finalement peut être dangereuse c'est
une passion qui peut être dangereuse
mais comme comme n'importe laquelle et
puis je trouve que les accidents de
chasse quand même sont relativement
faible par rapport à d'autres activités
par rapport à des accidents de la route
et par rapport à beaucoup d'autres
choses
ceci étant effectivement manipulation
d'armé c'est ça fait référence à la
sécurité c'est important que les règles
de sécurité soit renforcée pour éviter
au maximum les accidents inutile là je
sais que dernièrement à partir de
maintenant je crois
tous les dix ans les chasseurs devront
passer une formation de sécurité c'est
quelque chose de très bien effectivement
je pense qu'il ya des efforts à faire
pour qu'il y ait de moins en moins
d'accidents aujourd'hui vous avez 23 ans
vous êtes une femme qu'est ce que vous
espérez apporter justement à ce monde de
la chasse qui était un petit peu entre
guillemets vieilli et qui était la vente
à emporter d'alcool et alimentaire la
nuit considérant ayant observé qu'il y
avait là des attroupements qui n'étaient
pas de nature à favoriser le respect du
confinement est donc la maire de paris
d'ailleurs a eu l'occasion de s'exprimer
ce matin pour confirmer cela qu'à partir
de 22 heures à paris
eh bien il ya des fermetures des lieux
de distribution à emporter alimentaire
et de distribution et de points de
distribution d'alcool ça concerne aussi
les péniches j'ai vu dans l'arrêté du
préfet qui est parue donc les choses
sont très claires sur la question de
l'éducation nationale le ministre de
l'éducation jean michel blanquer air et
l'ensemble du personnel pédagogique a
mis en place un protocole sanitaire qui
est nécessaire qui est nécessaire et qui
permet de limiter toutes les situations
à risque
nous avons même renforcé ce protocole
vous l'avez vu avec le port du masque
recommandé par la société française de
pédiatrie jeu les petits dès l'âge de 6
ans ah oui mais c'est recommandé parce
que quand le virus circule beaucoup bas
ça peut freiner davantage la circulation
du virus
nous voulons pérenniser l'éducation
c'est sanctuarisé dans notre pays c'est
fondamental l'om est d'ailleurs a fait
une recommandation
aujourd'hui vous l'avez peut-être vu
appelant à maintenir les écoles et les
établissements scolaires ouverts à
chaque fois qu'il a lieu de se poser des
questions face au constat de situation
qui serait problématique et bien les
rectorats sont mobilisés et le ministre
de l'éducation nationale également
monsieur ministre raphaël barthet pour
faire ma radio vous avez beaucoup parlé
d' interprofessionnalité ce soir les le
maillage territorial des pharmacies est
très dense vont-ils être associé à cette
pluri professionnalité et à ses plans
dont il a été question et deuxième
question on a aussi parlé des tests
antigénique aujourd'hui près d'un sur
deux un pharmacien sur deux hésitent à
les faire manque de temps manque de
matériel comment peuvent-ils être
davantage incité encourager moi je
travaille beaucoup avec l'ordre des
pharmaciens qui fait un boulot
remarquable depuis le début de la
première vague
ils ont été indispensables pour
distribuer les matériels de protection
notamment les masques vous le savez
c'était des points ressources sur le
territoire justement parce qu'ils ont un
très fort maillage territorial et offre
un service en proximité pour pour les
français je les remercie à nouveau pour
leur mobilisation aujourd'hui alors
qu'ils sont mobilisés pour les vaccins
contre la grippe
ils sont mobilisés avec les tests
antigénique nous avons mis en place des
conditions qui les incite à le faire ils
peuvent commander cet instant titanic et
moi je suis je vais vous dire je suis
convaincu c'est un très grand nombre de
pharmaciens participeront à cet effort
de guerre à travers ce dépistage massif
et bonjours je vien vanesse pour bfm tv
alors après votre déplacement il ya
quelques jours dans un hôpital à corbeil
excusez moi je remets bien mon masque
vous avez eu un coup de sang à
l'assemblée nationale vous avez expliqué
notamment que la situation était et est
très grave
est-ce que plusieurs jours après vous
regrettez c'est cette forme
d'emportement vous avez devant les
députés
et on voit vous l'avez expliqué que les
chiffres sont très mauvais
est-ce que vous donner en quelque sorte
de nouvelles recommandations pour les
français notamment dans la sphère privée
personnes âgées par exemple qui sont des
populations à risque qui continue quand
même de d'aller faire leurs courses etc
voilà est-ce qu'il ya des nouvelles
recommandations
je vous dirai comment me l'a appris
quand j'étais plus jeune qu on n'a
jamais raison de perdre son calme même
s'il peut y avoir des raisons de le
perdre
la situation à laquelle vous faites
allusion nous étions avec jean castex le
premier ministre dans un déplacement
dans un hôpital et je suis revenu dans
l'hémicycle pour rendre compte à la
représentation nationale par l'exemple
des situations telles qu'elles sont
vécues et décrite par des soignants mais
aussi par les malades et les familles
des malades au quotidien et beaucoup de
bruit dans l'hémicycle ça arrive on
n'entend pas que sur les vidéos de
retransmission mais je peux vous
garantir que toi entendre sa propre voix
ça peut être compliqué et en
l'occurrence quand j'ai abordé la
question d'un jeune patient âgé de 28
ans réanimation on a le droit d'être
marqué quand on sort d'une chambre de
réanimation après cela un député pas
très loin s'est mis à crier
il va nous faire pleurer j'ai perdu mon
calme
je me suis je me suis emporté ça arrive
je n'ai jamais eu la volonté de demander
à la représentation nationale j'étais
vous savez parlementaire pendant
longtemps de sortir de l'hémicycle mais
je m'adressais plutôt à la personne qui
sait dans le compte-rendu de du débat
parlementaire sur la question que vous
posez des recommandations et des
nouvelles recommandations dans la sphère
privée n'est pas de nouvelles
recommandations
les recommandations elles sont déjà
compliquée à respecter tout au long de
la journée et tout au long de la nuit
c'est faire très attention attention à
soi attention à ses proches
encore plus attention quand on est avec
des personnes potentiellement fragile ne
pas connaître ce petit moment de
relâchement qui peut faire basculer des
vies être attentif
jérôme salomon l'a rappelé la règle des
six à table l'aération de son logement
le port du masque quand on le peut en
toute situation
tout cela fait partie des
recommandations à suivre au quotidien
bonjour monsieur le ministre florent
tardif pour ces newscan al plus on sait
que l'adhésion de la population vous en
avait parlé lors de cette conférence de
presse est important dans la lutte
contre cette épidémie le conseil
scientifique plusieurs fois dans
des avis qui l'a rendu qu'il vous a
communiqué d'ailleurs vous recommande de
vous appuyer sur une vision issus de la
société civile et non pas seulement sur
les orientations données par les experts
pour éclairer ces décisions est ce que
vous allez mettre en place oui ou non ce
conseil scientifique dans les prochains
jours prochaines semaines peut-être
prochain ben mercer le conseil
scientifique n'appelle pas avoir un
conseil scientifique citoyens il appelle
à respecter ce qu'on appelle la
démocratie sanitaire dans notre pays
c'était la belle doit de bernard
kouchner illustres prédécesseurs c'était
la loi du 4 mars 2002 qui créait les
droits des usagers transformant les
patients en usagers du système de santé
à part entière j'y suis très attaché à
la démocratie sanitaire et je connais
bien cette loi et donc nous faisons en
sorte que dans tous les territoires où
des cellules de coordination sont mises
en place
associant la ville et l'hôpital tous les
professionnels de santé
il y ait des représentants des usagers
au plus proche des territoires pour que
puisse être écouté la voix des usagers
mais qu'ils puissent également y avoir
des mécanismes de compréhension qu'ils
soient partagées et par ailleurs je
travaille en lien étroit avec les
associations des usagers des différentes
maladies notamment france aso santé que
j'ai réuni la semaine dernière encore en
visio conférence pour discuter avec eux
les informer des mesures qui seraient
prises et nous échangeons très
régulièrement ensemble que ce système a
été mis en place le conseil scientifique
avait raison de souligner monsieur le
ministre bertrand villeray pour
consulting news line lee a chu de
marseille a demandé une rti auprès de
l'asm pour l'hydro xi chloroquine
molécules qui a donné largement qui a
vraiment démontré son efficacité
alors que les médecins de ville vont
rentrer en jeu dans cette deuxième phase
est ce qu'on peut avoir un point une
décision définitive qui serait faite par
le ministère sachant que depuis le land
7 get on n'a pas eu vraiment de
décisions précises pour les médecins qui
veulent utiliser cette molécule
je vous remercie pour cette question pas
du tout orienté qui n'a pas du tout fait
bondir les médecins qui sont à côté de
moi en entendant dire que le traitement
avait prouvé son efficacité hélas
monsieur le traitement n'a pas démontré
son efficacité dans aucune étude
internationale et aucun pays ne le
recommande en pratique courante
ce qui se passe c'est que un institut où
un hôpital ou un professionnel de santé
a le droit de demander ce qu'on appelle
une utilisation dérogatoire pour un
médicament
non pas à traiter un patient mais tout
un groupe ou une cohorte de patients
pour une indication l'agencé nationale
de sécurité du médicament qui est
composé de professionnels de santé
indépendant a déterminé que les
conditions n'étaient pas réunies
permettant d'accorder cela considérant
que la revue littérature internationale
est pas le papier du lancet auquel vous
faites allusion mais l'ensemble de ce
qu'on appelle les méta analyse de revue
de littérature ne permettait pas non
seulement de considérer que le
traitement était très efficace comme
vous l'avez suggéré mais qu'en plus ils
pouvaient présenter dans certaines
situations assure risque pour la santé
des patients
l'asm a donc refusé d'accorder cette
autorisation c'est pas le ministre l
agence du médicament
mais je pense qu'elle a eu raison vu les
données de la science est néanmoins le
l'équipe en question a demandé aux
laboratoires de lui fournir directement
ses médicaments le laboratoire n'a pas
accepté de lui fournir ces médicaments
pour plusieurs raisons d'abord
considérant que les conditions
scientifiques n'étaient pas réunies à
nouveau c'est pas un ministre et deux
laboratoires producteurs lui même mais
également parce que dans le droit
si un médecin est libre de prescrire le
traitement qu'ils souhaitent à un
patient et bien il engage sa
responsabilité mais langage aussi celle
du laboratoire qui a fourni les
médicaments si c'est fait hors
indications nous prenons les deux
dernières questions
bonsoir monsieur le ministre olivier
lascars de sciences et avenir
vous avez parlé du redoutable du
dramatique engorgement qu'on constate au
niveau des hôpitaux
est ce que vous prévoyez déjà à ce
moment l'utilisation l'instauration
d'hôpitaux de campagne qui pourraient
être mises en place par l'armée
et à cet égard est ce que vous pouvez
nous dire un mot sur l'opération
résilience est ce qu'elle a toujours
cours est-ce que l'armée est toujours là
pour aider les personnels de santé dans
la crise qu'on connaît actuellement
je remercie de poser cette question
c'est vrai je n'en ai pas parlé mais le
service de santé des armées est
mobilisée depuis le premier jour dans
l'épidémie et d'ailleurs ils n'ont pas
pris de vacances puisqu'ils ont été
mobilisés en guyane sens a été
nécessaire dans les antilles lorsque
c'était nécessaire et là actuellement
l'hôpital militaire auquel vous faites
allusion il est en cours de déplacement
de déploiement pour la polynésie
française les places de réanimation sont
peu nombreuses en polynésie française
qui fait face à une diffusion importante
du virus avec très peu de possibilités
de faire des évacués
sanitaire comme vous pouvez l'imaginer
donc le service de santé et l'hôpital de
campagne et mobilisé vingt sept
destinations et je remercie florence
parly la ministre des armées qui s'est
mobilisé pour cela néanmoins vous avez
raison de le souligner il y a des des
médecins des soignants du service de
santé des armées qui sont dans vos
hôpitaux sont que parfois vous vous en
rendiez compte et qui prêtent main forte
aux équipes et d'ailleurs qui soigne et
certains hôpitaux militaires en france
qui acceptent des patients kobe comme
n'importe quel hôpital ne saurait non
sans messieurs ministre khadija la rési
que journaliste pour france télévisions
vous vous l'avez évoqué la reproduction
épidémique est forte
vous avez déployé un confinement un
confinement qui est moins strict que
celui déployé pendant la première vague
est ce qu'il faut s'attendre quand même
à peut-être un durcissement des mesures
de confinement dans les jours à venir si
cette reproduction épidémique continue
de grimper
le président de la république a été
clair quand il a annoncé le confinement
il a dit que peut-être que des mesures
complémentaires seraient nécessaires si
la situation épidémique le justifiait je
ne peux pas vous dire autre chose
d'autant que c'est très vrai que si la
situation épidémique justifient ils
pourraient être pris d'autres mesures
pour freiner la diffusion du virus savez
nous ne fonctionnons ne fonctionne pas
tout seul en vase clos
on regarde ce qui se passe autour de
nous on regarde ce qui se passe au
québec ce qui se passe en australie on
regarde ce qui se passe dans nombre de
pays européens qui nous entourent et qui
ont pris des mesures analogues aux
mesures que nous avons prises certains
pays ont pris une partie de ces mesures
est pas tout donc on regardait jeu
comment la situation épidémique a évolué
chez eux si ça suffit on le fait ça ne
suffit pas on prend d'autres mesures
donc on apprend les uns des autres on se
concerte beaucoup ce matin par exemple
j'étais en lien avec les ambassadeurs de
tous les pays de l'union européenne pour
pater partager les expériences de
l'ensemble des pays en matière de lutte
contre contre l'épidémie et donc c'est
aussi par l'observation est ce qu'on
appelle l'empirisme avec face à un virus
qui est un phénomène naturel une
catastrophe naturelle mais un phénomène
naturel et qu'on ne connaissait pas il
ya quelques mois comme l'a dit et mon
confrère tout à l'heure nous apprenons
constamment et donc à mesure que nous
apprenons nous apprenons aussi comment
lutter avec efficacité contre ce virus
aujourd'hui nous pensons nous
considérons et nous espérons tout à la
fois que le respect des mesures en
vigueur
le respect de ce confinement par les
français permettra
de faire baisser l'épidémie nous verrons
jour après jour semaine après semaine
si cela suffit ou si il faut prendre
d'autres types de mesures devant merci
je